well regardless of how the match goes we hope
that's the interest of the [ __ ] continues
on social media showing everybody the
tweet right now you guys have had some
fun going back and forth so are you know
i know i know it's all in fun and jest
oh my gosh oh there's the man oh my god i thought
we were about to end uh-oh okay first of all um
can i call you can i call you mister instead of mr
beast oh sure whatever you want whatever you want
these chess.com clowns okay and let's just call
them what they are feeding content hit me in the
dms they go hey do you want to hop on to talk on
mr beast bigger man i said no no this guy look
he's a little bit nervous like come on busy man
i don't want to do this to him come to find out
you're on here talking [ __ ] calling me one trick
pony all right at one point what is this what is
this mister i thought we had a thing going on i
thought this was like a there's a friendly bout
what i didn't call you one trick pony they called
you one i did i did and you didn't call danny
dumb and stupid for it but she is i mean to be
very yeah we'll see okay what so so like out
of curiosity like what's your real rating because
like your account you don't play a lot of games on
500 uh somewhere probably between 500 and 600 i
don't know wait is it actually you're debating
you're i wouldn't give away too much i thought you
were busy this was supposed to be my freebie match
i thought you had like work to do or something
17 youtube channels in like a food facility
have you been playing chess all of a sudden we'll
see i i don't want to give away too much the more
i tell you the more competitive advantage you have
jimmy this was the one match i wasn't supposed to
stress about i came in here meme i put up ten
thousand dollars i was trying to bait you to
put another 10k up so i could get easy clap 10k
you didn't even fall for it i know i noticed
ah okay but you're right here i i i will put
up 10k though we're both going on 10k winner
whoever wins not just one gib but whoever
wins overall gets 10 grand i'll match it
wow sure yeah that's that's fine games
are beginning right now here we go
and mr beast fog champs three
presented by grip six continues
and one e4 and mr beast is
stumped he's taking his time
okay scandinavian all right man this just i'm
gonna have to deal with john bartholomew all
over again the team scandy hi guys candy
here we go hey guys this is john all right
we just play scandy here he's gotten his
filthy hands on mr beast's opening repertoire
he's playing fast too so who is the better
part with all of you impersonation me or you
probably me well you need to do more of it you
can't just say two words and then uh have me award
you the bartholomew medal so did you not john what
do you think about the scandy you're not seeing my
april fool's video hi guys i got by starbucks on
the way all right so really proud of this video
and i wanted to bring it to you guys because it's
about 100 a game series and uh okay james candy
that was it was decent danny you know i'll give
you a b minus which is in my in my book is a
pretty good grade e5 though might be yeah that's
not bad i did have some prep look at this scandy
cause if he pushes again here and i take i'm
threatened wallace uh but it is attacked twice
so i'm fine as well so i'm gonna go here sticking
to the plan if he pushes i can just take with
my pawn it frees it up to capture because my
queen is no longer being attacked by this rook
castling is an idea i definitely want
to achieve at some point in my lifetime
i mean this is this is a high level game here and
i'm impressed not only with mr b's preparation but
how he's followed that through he centralized his
queen fundamentals now this is the pivotal moment
danny i really think that the next couple of
moves are going to decide the game will mr beast
understand the area of the board that he has
to play on that is the king side he's got to
start attacking white's game he's got to do it
quickly both players now down to five minutes
yeah and that's now he's below five minutes
and ludwig understands the danger which is
a very important thing if you're playing over
confidently uh you're much more likely to make
a blunder but i'm really really not liking this
this time consumption and he's done look at him go
that is really impressive danny dude seriously
right he's playing all the natural moves so
shout out to whatever kind of secret training uh
jimmy's been getting on on the side because he's
clearly clearly an underdog here uh surprising
people he's he is under five minutes so if this
game continues with both them you know playing
the way they are we it may just come down to
time pressure anyway which is part of life right
we don't play games that have hours and hours on
the clock anymore at least not in these online
events so uh we'll see but rook v8 what a move
so interpose i just take oh no i can't
take because the rook can't even see that
well that's fine we'll wait for
his move before we worry about ours
the flag i still he interposes might take here
because i still win a rook that's still a win
i lose a bishop in a knight
for a knight in a rook so
that's not actually that big of a
deal i'm not winning a queen boo hoo
carry his position honestly i don't even know
if it's that bad to go takes takes that might
even be good for him to be totally honest
queen sacrifice oh did i blunder what no no
you didn't we talked about that budwig did the
right thing when he started kind of getting
aggressive he played c4 even if it wasn't
objectively the best he started attacking
uh mr beast and uh and that was the pressure he
needed so i i i don't think that ludd is going to
blow this at this point he's improved so much
as well a lot like charlie from pogchamps one
right i just don't think that lubick doesn't win
this game now i think one of the most impressive
things was that was that uh ludwig played
quickly enough even though he was getting
outplayed so to speak right jimmy had a better
opening bloodwork was on on his heels a little
bit but he played quickly enough that um that he
was always in the game right and i think that's a
huge sign in experience right i think players as
they as they play more understand you can't solve
every problem on every move so you have to at
least give yourself a chance on the clock and
and then now now not only is he
winning but he's way up on time
well beast grabs the pawn here oh that's such a
good move that's a beautiful move let's listen
in on lubwig and see if he actually saw the pin
that he's going to mate him if he takes the rook
king can't move oh wow he did so i actually
pinned his wow bishop to a mate oh my gosh
and then i'll just do a little doubled up file and
i'll still go for a big it's a killer wallop dude
i'm super impressed by ludwig i obviously i do as
much as i can to to bag on him on a regular basis
no you gotta take your hat
i take with check
um i hmm i will form up this is flat out forget
we can go either here he's not
actually attacking us so this is
pretty irrelevant we just check the rook
look at the confidence now
we fork the rope
who is this imposter what all right game one
win this is oh my gosh this is just nastiness
who is this imposter and what have we done with
ludwig anyway uh how's it going let's double check
let's double check double check double check
there's only one real reason that you try to
beat mr beasts and it's for those sweet sweet
subscribers so let's get a live subscriber count
real time ludwig versus mr beast what do we
have here shirley surely i am catching up
i have to be
let's take a look any moment now
you're about to start seeing this
number on the left just rocket ship away
ludwig versus mr beasts you know it's it's like
pewdiepie versus t series pewdiepie versus coco
melon pewdiepie picks a lot of fights d4 we don't
see that often in pog jams i think lubbock's about
to pull uh oh bleep the game has started oops no
maybe not he played d5 and we saw we saw jimmy
give a fist pump there he was expecting d5 so
we'll see reminder to everyone tuning in these
guys threw down a 10 000 bet started by ludwig
on twitter this morning and uh beast backed it
live in an interview before the match started
so there's a lot on the line mm-hmm all right
g3 was played this was the line i was predicting
right with with uh queen h4 check john did this is
oh he finds bishop takes g3 even better the
rook is hanging wow i mean it's just crazy
and that is just devastation being wreaked upon
black sting that was the whole point of queen
h4 check and you can just tell by his eyes he
has his eyes are aimed right at white's king
right at white's king's side and despite the
best efforts of mr beast i mean blood is just
he's earning this one danny we got to take our
hats off you know mikhail tall right whom ludwig
tries to model his games after you know who
his favorite uh musical musical composer was
he was asked once and in a fit of
inspiration he said ludwig van beethoven
yeah that was i was i was cooking that up for
hours danny dude so this is my moment in the
sun there's a reason we have bad pun emotes
for you like on multiple channels ugh i'm
if i make another bad pun my hair myself might
start falling out and then i'll need a blood wig
who do you want to thank for these
i mean that was pretty good i'm just
oh i'm dying inside and this is my
job to make people feel this way bro
wow who do you want to thank for for how
far you've come with your bad pun game
it's you know it takes a village
danny it takes it takes many people
to allow me to descend to such to such depths
it's oh really it's taken many years of practice
oh let's tune into love and
see his thoughts on the final
pain rook check rook defended defended
here must interpose oh that worked out well
i would say so pre-move it because i
think it's forced oh my god the queen's
next level stuff we'll check again here grab pawn
like i said too much among us who is this imposter
uh we're going for a mate there's a bad pun
for you how's that the bullet world champion
wow instant chess wow
mopping it up here oh my gosh
um holy holy sick oh my lands oh let's go dude
never have i felt so good on a chess board i
i felt so calm today that was great
that was good chess oh yes it was
i'm speechless oh my lens i'm speechless my my
throat is dry a lot of people said that brain
wilson was maybe the clear favorite to win but
you know what dwight schrute has to say about that
because i could use some nice gaia key for mate
totally use some of that as well and to enjoy
with some of the park championships just made a
statement and said rain wilson is not the favorite
and pog champs will be presented by grip six white
fruit says false and we'll be right back next year
can you put it where i play him again first round
if we both make it next year i'm down next year i
will train i'll give myself a chest coach i'll
learn your first seven moves not your first six
i'll go all out that's gonna be the game changer
all right one year one year from today we rematch
in chess and we uh we put we put we put high
stakes on it i'll give you my stream key and you
give me your you just give me your youtube channel
oh uh yeah you can have like the reaction channel
we'll do another one later this year shockingly
i think uh you are like really good positionally
which is like weird and i am only good like
tactically and so you always got in better
positions but i just don't think you had like
the uh which i think is just a practice thing
straight up i think if we combine our talents we
make one decent chess player yeah if yeah that's
what i'm saying that's i'm going to secretly
wiretap you in on a zoom call for every future
chess match to hopefully help you have me uh beat
everyone blood i i don't know what to say man i
i don't know who you are anymore like who is this
imposter like what is going on with you just keep
doing it i guess just studying a bit here and
there all i gotta say is one final message to chat
if you guys go out and beat danny's bot on
chess.com he'll give you a free diamond membership
if you screenshot it instead of proof everybody
let's do it no one can do that everybody's already
beaten your butt and they've sent it to me i
got so many diamond memberships i got to give
away it's ridiculous dude i bought trash what do
you want for me just as the plan is simple and
then chokes all right well this isn't over we're
all right all right blood good luck guys later
everybody you're awesome thanks guys pleasure
to see you we'll see you in your next match
you